night to give a break or during the day
and so forth Cortney and I have shared a
good laugh together because we never did
this you know and I've been a committed
feminist you know virtually my entire
life but I've never I've never done that
it just seemed very contrived to me um
the easiest thing was to just you know
stick your breasts in the baby's mouth
and it will shut up and be calm right so
we we didn't do that but I know a lot of
people who do um and and I think the
broader point for me anyway is that I
think having you know three children and
the sort of bodily experience of being
pregnant birth breastfeeding was a real
sort of challenge to me as sort of an
equal rights feminist and equality
feminist I mean it really sort of threw
me for a loop and caused me to kind of
reconsider or reconstruct my notion of
feminism I will say on a much more a
sort of biological basis or rather and I
think that at that time I started
reading torille Moy and torille Moy sort
of brilliant book about what is a woman
right and she kind of teaches us I think
in that text that it's okay to embrace
biology and Badal eNOS without embracing
biological essentialism so that the body
you know doesn't have to determine your
lot in life or what you do with the body
but the body also doesn't need to be
denied either right it doesn't need to
be nine it doesn't need to jeopardize
sort of equal participation or equal
equal treatment now so so I have been
trying to construct and think of a
feminism that sort of incorporates the
unique the unique nature of the
reproductive functions of of the woman's
body including you know lactation and
therefore I'm really interested in kind
of reconstructing the public sphere
around what I think are universal values
of lactation potentially universal
values and I'm saying this to
incorporate I don't I don't think it it
may be trans exclusionary I don't think
it's transphobic and they may be the
same thing in your view okay um but to
construct the public sphere around what
I think should be universally revered
and practiced values of sort of you know
biology dependency chaos attachment that
I feel like you know has been kind of
the public sphere has been alienated and
sort of bled dry of those types of
practices yeah right exactly what that
what I need is one or two sadder to have
women's voices right and they think the
difference of opinion and to me men
taking very primary care doesn't require
breastfeeding or not at all but not the
boss right that the plate is really that
these discussions never go by
implication I think you're doing that
never include a discussion of what oh
what a gala terian reorganization not
only of space you know and how you know
who gets to do what where and everything
but also of the life trajectory I mean
why not take a you know a year off and
rest feed and you know a man also talked
about paternally if you know that people
get different stages in life might
really need to withdraw from this the
daily grind and the discussion of
pleasure is so far away from the or
displeasure so far away from these you
know the analytical question and yet I
think it should be folded in so I don't
want to say choice because we know where
that leads us you know I choose to
breastfeed and I choose not to
breastfeed you know this is that
horrible you know every woman on her own
you know no big social changes but just
a personal choice I don't want to even
use the word choice but one would like
there to be a range of possible
behaviors and support for them one good
thing about the La Leche League iris
they were just horrendous their rhetoric
was horrendous it out I'm sure that's a
funny part of your book but one great
thing about them was they said nobody's
helping women mm-hmm you know that was
that was a you know I was a member I
mean they were the pronatal ISM was you
know like absolutely mad I thought the
thing about the the Lachie league that
was moving was but it's it's part of
what I hear in right nice work is the
coldness of the manipulation and the
embedded stuff that you want and I don't
think it's breastfeeding I don't think
she's blaming breastfeeding for all
these terrible things that are happening
it's you know of a kind of lack of
elasticity in what men doing what women
do wait you like that term
elasticity yeah elasticity yeah Oh Todd
three-two-one
it's basically in support of your
position and mostly that support was
coming from people who had felt put upon
by the the activists so that speak
that's about to the huge the silent
majority who needed to be able to
discuss this I'm are you hoping for a
specific policy change to support these
people is they obviously need it well no
I'm hoping for I'm hoping for a policy
change that is maternity leave right but
that's not necessarily supporting the
women who are feeling put upon a policy
change like maternity leave would allow
women who want to breastfeed to do it in
a to actually breastfeed not to have to
pump breast milk so that somebody else
can feed their baby breast milk from a
bottle so that's the policy change that
I am interested in I'd also like WIC to
change its policies I'd like to see the
enhanced food package eliminated and for
that sort of coercive mechanism of that
specifically geared toward inducing poor
people to choose breastfeeding I'd like
to see that eliminated but what I'm
really hoping for more fundamentally I
think and I think what a lot of those
women were saying that they they're not
necessarily experiencing that shaming
that's coming from from on top from
policy it's coming from everywhere it's
social and if we change the conversation
and we sort of start to look at what
we're actually doing and and
also I think if we look at it as
something that's actually bigger than
the Mommy Wars so I think that you know
this this has long been dismissed by
identifying it as an issue that is just
about mommy Wars and so I mean even
calling it that is very dismissive it's
just sort of what these mothers do
because they're so jealous and angry
with one another if you look at it as
something that goes far beyond the Mommy
Wars that has all of these larger
implications and that is that's that's
insidious in these many ways it'll
change the conversation and a lot of the
my the way I read or heard a lot of the
comments that I've received is this it's
the conversation that needs to change
and that we're hoping that your book
will do some of that work in changing
the conversation any more comments
because there was a question over there
I really enjoyed talk I think it's very
eye-opening I think it's very
educational history
I don't yeah I can hardly hear you
okay so thank you so um you know I I
enjoyed your talk I found it was
interesting and eye-opening I agree with
the points that you're making and I
don't think that I'd be saying anything
with which you would disagree if I were
to say well you know we know why things
cash out this way it's because of
capitalism right whether you breastfeed
or the bottle feed or formula feed or
whatever it's going to be majorly
commercialized because that is the
capitalist world you live and likewise
the reason why cashes out in the ways
that you're describing is because of
patriarchy right point of patriarchy is
that regardless of what women do
regardless of the choices they make
they're criticized for it they're over
managed in doing it you know etc but the
punchline of your book is not Apple ism
or patriarchy its lack to visit and I
mean on the one hand I understand why
because it's 2015 and we don't want to
read books anymore that say guess what
it
the problem is capitalism right good
worry at this point but there's kind of
a problem with that and and let me draw
an analogy because you know we all know
now that the anti-vaxxer position is
wrong right we know that those people
have no medical lab we know that what
they're doing is socially irresponsible
because it's not contributing to herd
immunity and you know if you if any of
you are on the internet I'm sure you've
noticed over the last couple of years
that it's like a pastime on you know
Twitter Facebook whatever especially
among the left you just castigate these
anti-vaxxer like these idiots and these
like socially irresponsible morons I've
had a friend point out to me that like
there's there's a problem with that and
the problem with that is the reason why
people were attracted to the anti-vaxxer
position which in my memory dates to
like around the 90s maybe it was earlier
than that they didn't just have to do
with the fear of autism and that one
doctor guy who's been discredited the
reason why people were attracted to it
in attachment parenting circles and
whatever is because you know the moment
that you get pregnant you're introduced
to this medical system and the social
system and social services delivery
system and you know in normal pressure
that is incredibly condescending
contradictory judgmental and and
invalidates all of the choices that you
make and forces upon you all kinds of
unnecessary forms of intervention and
monitoring and so on and so forth
and you can understand why people turned
to an anti vaccination physician why
some mothers for example turn to an anti
vaccination position because they were
tired of these unnecessary interventions
they were trying to use their own
judgment and in their judgment that
seemed the best for their child and so
when we very easily and and Smyly
denigrate that anti addition we can sort
of get that that's there was like a
little background to it and so I think
the same it's feeding you know about
everything that's going on here and that
can be sort of the problem with having
as your target or punchline activism
rather than
and you know patriarchy or capitalism or
whatever like that sort of again part of
this is the product of people trying to
fun trying to make better more more
autonomous more decisions and you know
it's fun kind of just that was attempt
to help women and also to point out that
like just skill and then it's something
that knowledge yeah you know just you
shouldn't just throw people in the deep
end and say it'll happen yeah don't just
want to raise that as sort of like I
like the fact catalogued all of this
empirical evidence into one book really
point out how problematic black is but
there's I have that own típica thrust in
elephant
shall I respond yeah yeah I think this
is it right you why don't you respond
and then we'll close and have wine so
the La Leche initially when La Leche
initially started it was explicitly
understood by those women who started La
Leche League as a pushback against the
medicalization of childbirth and of
infant feeding they were responding
against doctors who were telling them
that they had to formula feed their
babies that they had to formula feed a
particular amount in every feeding that
they had to feed on a 4-hour schedule so
it was very regimented you know
childbirth pregnancy and baby feeding
were all extremely regimented and they
were regimented they were things that
were regimented by male doctors and so
it was absolutely a push back against
that medicalization of the female body
and things that ought properly to be the
purview and responsibilities of women
and mothers in particular right so there
is that history to it and a lot of
people are firmly embedded in that
history right that's that history has
not disappeared that's one of the
reasons why so many people are committed
to breastfeeding but the point that I'm
trying to make and in my book is that
we've we've swung in the other direction
on the pendulum right and so there were
there were those perfectly reasonable
commitments and instincts that were you
know Pro woman and pro nature and anti
medicalization and then and now
breastfeeding advocates are relying on
medical science and on doctors to push
their agenda and so you that it's swung
too far in the other direction and I
think
making the same point mullahs making
when you say you know the problem is
capitalism the problem is the patriarchy
that's what mullahs saying right she's
saying you're saying it's all the fault
of breastfeeding but in fact you know
it's because we have discrimination in
the workplace and it's because you know
women's voices aren't heard etc so you
know absolutely there are bigger
problems in the world unfortunately this
was our worst problem
[Laughter]
[Applause]
here's a look at some of the current
best-selling non-fiction books according
to the New York Times starting the list
Donaghy C coats winner of last year's
National Book Award and finalist for the
National Book Critics Circle Award looks
at the current state of black America in
between the world and me Fox News host
Brian Kilmeade is next who along with
Don Jager provides a history of the
Barbary wars in Thomas Jefferson and the
Tripoli pirates another Fox News host
Bill O'Reilly along with Martin Dugard
are on the list with a look at how the
attempted assassination of Ronald Reagan
shaped his presidency in killing Reagan
fourth is Atul Gawande 'he's examination
of end-of-life care in being mortal
followed by two-time Pulitzer Prize
winning author David McCullough's look
at the birth of flight in the Wright
brothers Donald Trump is next with his
book crippled America which outlines his
plans to improve the US economy reform
the health care system and strengthen
the military the New York Times list of
best-selling non-fiction books continues
with Helen McDonald's H is for hawk
followed by a collection of essays on
mortality from the late physician Oliver
Sacks
Pulitzer Prize winning author Stacy
shifts examination of the 1692 Salem
witch trials and historian Mary beards
exploration of the founding of ancient
Rome finish off this week's look at some
of the current nonfiction bestsellers
according to the New York Times many of
these authors have or will be appearing
on book TV you can watch them on our web
site book TV org
you're watching book TV on c-span 2 this
weekend we're visiting Hartford
Connecticut to talk with local authors
and tour the city's literary sites with
the help of our local cable partner
Comcast next we learn about the
Hutchinson family an anti-slavery
singing group during the 1840s with
Scott GAC author of singing for freedom
[Music]
[Music]
there 18:44 song get off the track which
is a campaign song for the Liberty Party
the first national anti-slavery Party in
the United States history one of the
most popular songs of the Hutchinson
family singers indeed it becomes it
becomes somewhat the anthem of the
anti-slavery movement in the 1840s and
1850s
[Music]
nation
[Music]
the book is on the Hudgens and Family
Singers this group of anti-slavery
singers who were born in New Hampshire
in the the late tens and early 1820s
they are a family group thus the name
Hutchinson Family Singers a group of
three brothers and one sister I
they are anti-slavery singers who are
one of the most popular musical acts of
the 1840s and 1850s and I wrote it
because the the uniqueness of the
Hutchinson's and of their story but also
the one really big question which is how
does a group that sings for a social
reform social activists right musical
social activists how does this group
become so popular initially there are
three the three brothers Judson Jesse
and ASA Hutchinson are somewhat
captivated by this idea of music they
come from a large farming family in
Milford New Hampshire which is on the
southern border of of New Hampshire the
southern border right with with
Massachusetts and large farming family
mainly male male children it's a it's a
family of 11 boys and to two girls one
of the things that happens in the
Hutchinson family right there the two
oldest brothers are going to kind of
split what's the family farm or in line
to split the family farm the next series
of brothers actually move with their
families out to what's considered the
West at that time into Ohio and into
Illinois and then you have the youngest
series of brothers who are going to form
three quarters of the Hutchinson Family
Singers they moved to to actually to
Lynn Massachusetts these somewhat early
industrialized areas in Lynn the the
Hutchinson's connect their background in
music that was developed through the
Baptist Church they had they come from a
family that was very active in in the
Baptist community in New Hampshire and
it taught them the church taught them
how to sing the church taught them how
to to to read music music is a little
bit problematic particularly in rural
New England at the time right it's it's
dangerous people who are musicians are
seen as immoral perhaps in some way and
so of course the church provides a a
moral space for people to be able to
sing because they're singing the word of
the Word of God and the Hutchinson
family as a whole is very active in the
musical community in New Hampshire
through the Baptist Church one of their
brothers is a is the choral director of
the church and also provides music
lessons for for the community and the
Hutchinson's kind of tried to run with
that when they're in Lynne and they get
this idea that maybe we could become a
performing troupe and so in 1841 they
decide to try their luck as three
brothers and they tour New England and
upstate New York and it's a complete
flop they grew up they claimed in the
mountains of the old Granite State the
white mountains even though the
Hutchinson's incidentally Milford New
Hampshire I think the highest point is
only a couple of hundred feet and they
don't actually visit the White Mountains
in New Hampshire until 1843 nonetheless
they present themselves as coming from
the mountains of the old Granite State
and they they try and experiment which
is they bring their youngest sister 12
year old Abbie Hutchinson on the stage
with them and these two things
connecting to their the geographic
location of of New England generally and
the White Mountains in particular the
soil along with bringing a be on stage
creates a family-based presentation that
instantly resonates with audiences and
so this this quartet creates the
foundation for the Hutchinson Family
Singers that begins to work so one
example in 1842 the Hutchinson's play at
Dartmouth
College and this is one of the early
concerts with Abbie Hutchinson and on
the first night they go out they play to
the audience it's all men they applaud
it's all great next night they come out
and it's a mixed gender audience with
children right men their wives and
children have come the first night the
men are literally checking them out
right is this going to concert going to
be acceptable for my wife and for my
children to to experience and so this is
the kind of gender dynamic that that the
Hutchinson's are kind of playing around
with in their stage presentation at this
particular moment in time but in 1842
there is an important event in the fall
that starts to push the Hutchinson's in
new directions in October of 1842 a
fugitive slave George Latimer and his
wife Rebecca arrive in Boston
seven days later they are recognized by
a friend of their of their Virginian
master who then contacts the master the
master context the United States marshal
in Boston and they are immediately
thrown into jail as fugitive slaves and
there is going to be a trial over
whether or not the lattimer's are
fugitive slaves and whether or not they
should be reinstated
on to the Fugitive Slave Clause of 1793
and the Hutchinson's are involved in
that by virtue of living in Lynn
Massachusetts at the time and they begin
there they're kind of steps towards
perhaps becoming anti-slavery singers so
this idea of immediate ISM which the
Hutchinson's will pick up on from their
own Christian background is certainly
one of the factors in play the idea of
social betterment that connects also to
a youth movement many of the
Hutchinson's fans from what we can tell
were were younger of a younger
generation a generation that is
increasingly mobile socially mobile and
geographically mobile they're moving to
cities from from
rural rural areas the United States at
this moment in time is predominantly a
rural nation it's not until 1890s and
then afterward that we consider the
United States an urban population would
happen throughout the Northeast
itinerant ministers would travel from
town to town stay for one or two weeks
create a revival people would literally
come in camp out for for a week have a
variety of celebrations have awakened
personal spiritual awakenings and in
many ways these revivals are the
earliest examples of kind of a popular
culture in the United States these mass
entertainments thousands of people at
the largest ones would show up so these
kind of very personal live performances
whether they be of religion or whether
they be soon of music are though are one
of the earliest sites of entertainment
in in the United States and the
Hutchinson's you know kind of branch
that divide if there is a divide but
branch these two two these two areas the
the music the religious realm and and
the musical realm the Hutchinson's will
be bear witness to the great
anti-slavery sensation or the of the
anti-slavery circuit the sensation of
the anti-slavery circuit of the eighth
of 1842 who is Frederick Douglas
Frederick Douglass becomes the the the
most one of the most notable persons
through his speeches at anti-slavery
meetings throughout the Northeast in
1842 and so throughout this moment of
1842 the George Latimer incident seeing
Frederick Douglass and and perhaps you
know hearing and of course hearing him
speak the Hutchinson's
you know decide to take that step and
they will actually perform at the
American anti-slavery society meeting in
1843 they'll perform in Boston a little
before that kind of their first forays
into into anti-slavery singing and they
do this in in very kind of formal
meeting settings and they do it
brilliantly
so the conscience ins will quite
literally use tunes that other people
are using they often call
from revival tents songs that people
were singing in a in a in a church
setting or in certain cases
there'll be tunes that are circulating
in popular consciousness this is an era
of blackface minstrels who are creating
a variety of popular tunes and the
Hutchinson's will kind of borrowed from
blackface minstrelsy the tunes and
create their kind of anti minstrels
lyrics on top of it so one example is
one example of a minstrel tune that they
that they borrow from will be old Dan
Tucker it's their 1844 song get off the
track which is a campaign song for the
Liberty Party the first national
anti-slavery party in the United States
history one of the most popular songs of
the Hutchinson family singers indeed it
becomes it becomes somewhat the anthem
of the anti-slavery movement in the
1840s and 1850s is is a old Dan Tucker
sped up that is they move they used a
faster tempo but again they're using a
tune that everybody could recognize and
then putting their own lyrics on top of
it they refuse to sing to to segregated
audiences a concert spaces in the 1840s
and 1850s are and and of course
certainly throughout the 19th century
and then into the 20th century or almost
always accepted Hutchinson family singer
shows and a few other examples are
almost always segregated right
african-americans are given the seats in
the way back there's often a special
section but at the very least whites and
blacks are not to sit together in the
same rows certainly not interspersed
among among one another the Hutchinson's
actually try their best to promote a
desegregated audience this gets them a
lot of criticism this gets amana curses
in Boston this creates a famous mob
incident in 1847 in Philadelphia where a
mob threatens to shut down mmm musical
fund hall where the Hutchinson's are
playing because they're playing to a
desegregated audience and the mob
dictates to the theater owners that if
they allow the HUD
since to play to blacks and whites
together that they will literally burn
down the hall this is a somewhat common
threat that has been played out in
Pennsylvania in Philadelphia in
particular on several occasions where
halls buildings have been burnt down for
anti-slavery kind of activism and Abby
Hutchinson is known as the Jenny Lind of
America before Jenny Lind of course
makes her visit and so she's upheld is
this kind of ideal of American womanhood
and ludlow follows the group wherever
they go
his clippings are still available in you
know newspaper clippings are available
in folders at the public library in
Milford New Hampshire still and the to
Ludlow and Abbie marry in 18-49 and
Abbie's forced to retire from the group
in the immediate aftermath the brothers
quite literally start resorting to
fisticuffs before shows right they get
into fights they seem to have lost their
grounding their egos are getting into
the way ASA upholds of high moral
standard Judson and John seemed to have
a lot of dalliance 'as with groupies and
they are married at the time
there are ways in which they mirror kind
of our ideal of rock musicians of the
1960's and 1970's and these kind of
internal struggles really ripped the
group apart you know by and large after
the Civil War the Hutchinson Family
Singers ASA moves out out west the
brothers had founded Hutchinson
Minnesota and and then ASA will move to
Colorado ASA will live out west for the
rest of his life John will be remained
centered in in Lynn Massachusetts Abbey
will remain in New York and in Orange
New Jersey New York City and Orange New
Jersey and travel the world she'll be in
Egypt and a variety of other places she
she has she's married again Ludlow
Hutchinson Ludlow Patton was
extraordinarily wealthy to whom she weds
and and the Hutchinson's won't be that
social voice that they were in the 1840s
and 1850s and by and large they will be
they'll be what a lot of a lot of
singers from the 1960s are today right
they make money off of what they once
were
there had been xin in many ways they're
not creating new music they're repeating
their old music they're going onstage as
a relic in many ways that people want to
remember the older age in many ways and
that younger generations are curious
about all these stories that their
parents had about this moment oh we used
to listen to you know so-and-so and you
go and you kind of share that legacy
that way but they're never never reached
the the fame and celebrity that they
once had during the 1840s and 1850s the
legacy of the Hutchinson is important in
several different in several different
ways to us today I mean one you starts
with this kind of musical legacy which
is this combination of social activism
of commercialization you know being a
giant celebrity that that we again most
often locate in the 1960s or 1970s and
certainly you know maybe the 1930s
during the Great Depression and during
some of the labor struggles but maybe
not that much celebrity or at least not
that much economic success the
Hutchinson's had this all in the 1840s
[Music]
[Music]
for more information on book TVs recent
visit to Hartford and the many other
destinations on our city store go to
c-span org slash
city store
this is book TV on c-span - television
for serious readers here's our primetime
lineup tonight at 6:15 p.m. Eastern
Peter Navarro looks at the likelihood of
a conflict between the United States and
China starting at 8:00 Catherine's off
profiles several Arab women who are
working to change the Middle East then
at 9:00 former senators Tom Daschle and
Trent Lott weigh in on partisan politics
on afterwards that's followed at 10:00
with Matt Ridley's examination of
evolution through technology religion
education and more and we wrap up book
TV in primetime at 11:00 with Cara
Plutonian PSA's in technology that will
enhance our senses that all happens
tonight on c-span two's book TV
welcome my name is jinilee I'm a vice
president here at the Cato Institute and
I'll be your moderator today thank you
all for coming out to the first Cato
event of 2016 today we're going to
spread the New Year's cheer and take the
chill out of your bones with an in-depth
look at remote controlled executions the
creeping surveillance state and the
seeming permanence of the imperial
presidency so merry new year our focus
today is the extraordinary new book by
Charlie savage power wars inside Obama's
post 9/11 presidency Charlie has been
with the New York Times since 2008 and
he has been the indispensable reporter
on executive power issues since well
before that in 2007 while with the
Boston Globe he won the Pulitzer Prize
for his work on the Bush administration
signing statements his 2007 book
takeover the return of the imperial
presidency was named one of the best
books of the year by watch The
Washington Post Slate and Esquire to
describe power wars as comprehensive
would I think undersell it I mean look
at this thing you can't actually there's
no index available in the book you have
to actually print out 50 pages of index
from Charlie's website it's a mammoth
undertaking and well worth the effort it
breaks new ground and new stories based
on interviews with over a hundred and
fifty current and former officials it's
basically a one-man 9/11 Commission
report on how we got to where we are
today
power Wars picks up where takeover left
off with the arrival of a new
administration that had pledged to quote
turn the page on the executive
a grand iseman of the bush-era and yet
as Charlie writes early on in the new
president's tenure Obama's policy
choices that departed from Bush era
programs dwindled and those that
continued or even expanded Bush era
programs rose from a fierce campaign of
drone strikes whose targets would
include an American citizen to the
perpetuation of a sprawling and
voracious surveillance apparatus people
across the ID ideological spectrum would
voice with increasing intensity what
became a defining accusation not just of
the moment but of the entire presidency
Obama was acting like Bush our
distinguished commentator today is
Michael Glennon professor of
international law at Tufts University
and the former legal counsel to the
Senate Foreign Relations Committee his
2014 book national security and double
government was the most disturbing thing
I read that year in it professor Glennon
asks the key question why does national
security policy remain constant even
when one president is replaced by
another who as a candidate repeatedly
forcefully and eloquently promised
fundamental changes in that policy he
identifies three possible causes for
this striking degree of policy
continuity between the two
administrations one possible answer is a
rational good-faith threat assessment by
political actors these were the policies
we need we needed given the threats that
we faced another is the enormous
political pressures brought to bear on
the presidency whether rational or not
but professor Glennon puts his emphasis
on a third cause one that's gone under
recognized what he calls an emergent
autocracy made up of national security
insiders
we've moved beyond a mere imperial
presidency he writes to a structure of
double government in which even the
president exercises little substantive
control over the overall direction of
u.s. national security policy
the Boston Globe summed up the Glennon
thesis rather starkly as vote all you
want the secret government won't change
now you can find evidence for all three
of these causes in the pages of power
Wars and reading it it struck me that
looking for a single culprit behind the
persistence of the imperial presidency
is something like looking for a mono
causal explanation of the American
obesity crisis are we fat because of
high fructose corn syrup or super-sized
portions or because we watch five hours
of TV on average a day yes like our
expanding waste lines our expanding
presidency is depressingly
overdetermined but anyone who wants to
figure out how we got to where we are
today
and if we can possibly get back we'll
have to start with power wars to kick
off that conversation please welcome
Charlie Savage
[Applause]
well thank you very much for the kind
introduction gene I like the idea of the
one-man 911 Commission I could listen
you talk all day and thank you very much
Michael as well for coming down to from
Boston who participate in this event I
really liked his book I was recommended
to me as I was telling him just a couple
minutes ago by a former lawyer in the
Obama White House about a year and a
half ago when I was researching my book
and we were talking about the dilemmas
and difficulties they had encountered
once they had come into office and I
immediately ordered it and devoured it
and cite it in my book and thank you to
all of you I was wondering whether we
would have any turnout today it's so
it's so cold
after the ridiculously warm December I
was like what I go out so I'm amazed and
heartened to have such a good crowd and
those watching on c-span as well so let
me I'm just gonna talk maybe 15 minutes
about my book and then Michael will talk
a little bit and then we'll have a
conversation and move to audience
questions so I'll start with a story of
my book so I yeah I've been in
Washington covering national security
issues and legal policy issues since
2003
I sort of rode the wave in on Abu Ghraib
and the attempt by Senator McCain to
impose a ban on torture and the signing
statements by a Bush that came out of
that as well as the revelations about
warrantless wiretapping by my future
colleagues the New York Times I was then
at the Boston Globe and this was and
essentially became a specialist of this
layer of what the government has been
doing the sort of continuing dilemmas
and legal fights over executive power
national security individual rights
after 9/11 and you may remember in
January of 2009 when President Obama was
inaugurated there was this moment in
which it looked like the war on terror
was suddenly abruptly over he of course
run on a platform of change from George
Bush's global war on terrorism you've
been a big critic on the campaign trail
of how the government had conducted
itself in the years after 9/11 and his
inaugural address talked about the
you know getting away from the sense
there had to be a trade-off between
constitutional ideals and security and
among the first things he did was issue
a series of executive orders promising
less secrecy closing CIA black site
prisons banning torture ordering
Guantanamo closed and it really looks
like it was over and this thing that I
had become a specialist in and a couple
colleagues of mine like Scott Shane
Marquez Eddie and so forth at the times
did for a living was no longer going to
be available and I remember joking to
Scott I think it was that we were gonna
have to find new jobs maybe there was an
opening in the sports department and we
can you know keep paying the rent
somehow but very quickly it became
apparent to me that it was not over that
there was gonna be much greater
continuity in the counterterrorism
policies of the new administration with
the old one than the expectations
created by then-senator Obama's campaign
rhetoric some of his incoming cabinet
members in sort of little nervous
remarks during their confirmation
testimony had affirmed that in fact they
thought it was lawful for the government
to hold terrorism suspects without trial
under the laws of war that they were
going to continue the practice of
rendition transferring people to other
countries for one Intelligence Agency to
the next based only on diplomatic
assurances that there would not be
mistreatment was which was exactly
Bush's policy at least on paper as well
they shut down temporarily military
commissions but they done so in a way
that looked like they were keeping the
door open to resuming them which is of
course exactly what happened they were
stirring the state secrets privilege in
court to continue blocking lawsuits
about torture and surveillance that they
had inherited from the Bush
administration and all that was sort of
apparent by two or three weeks into the
new administration and so I called up
the new White House and said I was
planning on writing a story about this
surprising emerging continuity and one
difference between the old
administration and the new one was the
Obama administration wanted to or at
least was willing to engage with me when
I
call the Bush administration say hey I'm
gonna write a story about the signing
statement that says you can you know
torture notwithstanding the anti torture
law they would kind of blow me off the
administration called me into the White
House and I went in and I talked to Greg
Craig who was Obama's first White House
Counsel in his office and we we went
through this sort of litany of things
that weren't changing and he explained
that they were not going to have a shoot
from the hip
you know bumper sticker slogan abrupt
changes to government policies they were
going to look carefully at everything
they had inherited and move deliberately
and that involved going out to Langley
into the Pentagon and so forth even
during the transition and getting
briefed by the members of the permanent
national security establishment the sort
of subject of Michael's book about what
the programs were why they were
necessary why they've been in put in
place what they were doing
what revoking them would entail and he
argued that this you know whether it's
civil liberties people on the left or
the right place like this who are upset
by that or was Bush administration
veterans who were seeing you know
claiming vindication by that that both
sides were wrong they were charting
their own course and people should just
give them time to let this work out so I
continued to cover these things and I
became very interested in the targeted
killing of the American citizen Anwar
al-awlaki brought a lawsuit along with
the ACLU two different lawsuits to try
to make them reveal their legal thinking
about the scope and limits of the
government's power to target an American
citizen who had not been convicted in a
court in a sort of national security
situation like that and then I
eventually began to teach a class with
Mike Davidson a retired lawyer from the
Senate Intelligence Committee at
Georgetown University on national
security the Constitution in which we
had to organize all this stuff that I
had spent a decade immersing myself in
in a way that a educated but non
specialists could understand we started
I sort of started to structure what what
are the ten things you really need to
know about everything that's been
unleashed about surveillance where
there's
it's not clear what the law means
anymore or new technologies have
challenged the old rules that weren't
written for these situations what are
the 10 things you need to know about
detention or interrogation or leak
investigations or secrecy or war powers
we're 21st century situations have
reopened questions that seem to be
settled in the 20th century because the
premises are all different now you know
the laws of war written for nation-state
armies in uniform clashing on a literal
battlefield how that gets applied by
analogy to a transnational non-state
actor armed conflicts like the war
against al-qaida has opened unending
some tensions and dilemmas that are
fascinating and unresolved and the idea
was that the students would learn this
stuff and then the next time someone
gets arrested for terrorism and that are
on CNN that are arguing about whether
this person should be read them random
warning or when should be prosecuted in
a military commission or an article
three civilian court they would be
equipped to understand what it was that
was sort of the unspoken assumptions
behind those arguments and where it came
from and then in the midst of that
Edward Snowden leaks massive amounts of
documents about the surveillance state
and becomes clearer than ever that Obama
has not changed really at all the NSA
apparatus that he inherited including
the bulk collection of domestic phone
records and at that that's when I
decided that I this this stuff really
needed to be organized in a book I
couldn't do it justice in newspaper form
there was just too much material and
everything really related to everything
else you could you know you couldn't
really understand what you were looking
at in the argument about closing
Guantanamo if you didn't also understand
what had gone on with CIA torture and
the attempt to prosecute and then the
failure to prosecute and why
Commission's were collapsing which in
turn turned on you know what had
happened on Christmas 2009 and the
attempted underwear bombing and how that
created this big fight in New York and
these things were an embedded web of
complexity and to tell it systematically
was the goal
so I've spent as the introduction
mentioned I spent the next couple years
organizing and researching I talked when
I when I say I talked to 150 people I
don't mean that I had 150 interviews I
had probably a thousand interviews
because I kept circling back to people
that I trusted and cross-referencing
memories of accounts of internal
deliberations and as I would focus on
this and re research it and then focus
on that do you remember this someone
else told me it happened this way does
that correct is there a nuance I'm
overlooking and I assembled this book
which is in some ways organized
similarly to my Georgetown class there
are thematic chapters and then
chronology within stories within chapter
and a rising you know so a lot of it is
sort of case studies you're the fly on
the wall you're trying to you're you get
to be in the Situation Room as actual
people who want to think of themselves
as obeying the rule of law are dealing
with difficult situations in the world
and none of the options are perfect
there's no clear answer everything comes
with dumb downsides and risks and why do
they make the decisions they do what
were the options they discarded why they
discard them so there's a lot of case
studies and and how does that illustrate
these recurring frictions of the rules
not being clear anymore and 20 weren't
written for these situations and then
but then arising from that or some big
picture questions and the biggest of
them all is how is it that Obama has had
so little change from the policies that
he inherited from the second term Bush
administration where did this disconnect
come from is that why do people keep
saying he's acting like Bush how did we
get here what happened and one of the
takeaways that I put forward in this
book as an argument is that what it
means to act like Bush is can mean more
than one thing in it's easier to see now
than it was at the time during the Bush
years when you know organizations like
Cato were having conferences and and you
know in which people had panel
discussions criticizing bush or there
were rallies and so forth there was that
there were two different strands of
criticism that were entangled together
but are in fact distinct there was a
rule of law critique and
there was a Civil Liberties critique so
the Civil Liberties critique says it's
inherently wrong to have a warrantless
wiretapping program or to torture or to
have a system of military commissions
because the state should not have that
power
visa via the individual this is
unamerican the rule of law critique is
agnostic about whether with the
exception of torture whether these
things are a good idea or a bad idea
torture is always illegal but and maybe
these are a good idea given the
challenges of 21st century transnational
terrorism but it's focused on the
process the president doesn't get to
break the law and so if a federal
statute says you must get a warrant to
wiretap on domestic soil even in wartime
the president doesn't get to say in
secret on the commander-in-chief I can
ignore that and disregard it the
president has to go to Congress and
persuade lawmakers to remake the law so
that statutes authorized rather than
forbid what it is he or she wants to do
and so that one of the big differences
between the rule of law critique and the
Civil Liberties critique is that the
rule of law critique is fixable if
something is violate civil liberties the
only way to fix it is to stop doing that
thing if something violates the rule of
law Congress can pass a bill to change
the law so that it no longer violates
the rules law and in fact in the second
term of the Bush administration Congress
passes the military commissions Act
passes with Senator Obama's vote the
FISA Amendments Act and we know now if
we didn't know at the time the
intelligence Court was issuing secret
rulings that took these unilateral
programs that were collecting everyone's
phone records and email records and
routed them in a you know somewhat ten
dishes claim that the Patriot Act
authorized them imposed court oversight
and so by the time Obama becomes
president if you think the problem with
that act with Bush that acting like bush
means violating the rule of law
international security sphere the
problem is largely fixed if you think
the problem is that acting like bush is
violating civil liberties the problem is
not fixed because of who cares if
Congress is blessed it the government
just needs to stop doing this thing so
the part two of that analysis is prop
barack obama is a lawyer obviously Joe
Biden is a lawyer
Bush and Cheney are not lawyers there
are CEOs by background they had very few
lawyers but that surrounded them they
were perhaps the least lawyerly
administration ever a few lawyers they
led him to the room had very these
sweeping idiosyncratic theories of
executive power well we've gone from
that extreme to the opposite extreme
this is probably the most lawyerly
administration ever not only arbok Obama
and Joe Biden
law school graduates they are clearly
the most comfortable when they're
talking to fellow law school graduates
who analyze problems the same way who
speak the same lingo so they fill the
upper ranks of their administration with
lawyers fellow lawyers and policymaking
roles there's a million examples I can
give the easiest one is say Secretary of
State Bush's two secretaries of state
condi rice and : pal are not lawyers
Obama's Hillary Clinton and John Kerry
are but that replicates itself
throughout the upper ranks of the
national security political apparatus
and so if they're lawyerly thinking
they're literally approach to problems
is brought to bear on what do they think
the problem is with Bush not
surprisingly they are overwhelmingly and
if you go back and look at transcripts
of things from the Bush years the they
were the ones articulating the rule of
law critique not the civil liberties
critique and this was just sort of
obscured in the campaign especially when
similar Obama is in the primary against
Hillary Clinton and they're competing
for the affections of a liberal base
that's very upset with Bush and Cheney
and no one is gonna you know they don't
want to say well I think what they're
doing is maybe okay is they stood the
wrong way but it's fixed now so no
worrys they were like this is wrong but
if you go back and you parse what they
were saying what Obama was saying
especially it was quite delivered in
fact I tell a story about how in 2007
August when Senator Obama gives his big
national security speech at the Woodrow
Wilson Center down the road from here he
was originally going to say I'm against
military commissions and jeh Johnson
who's now that Homeland Security
Secretary and was he's first turned the
Pentagon general counsel but a campaign
adviser says you don't know what
problems you might encounter as
president you need to maintain
flexibility and they rewrite the speech
so that he says I'm against the military
commissions Act of 2006 and people hear
that and think he's against commissions
but really he said he's
that Commission's that were set up that
way which leaves him open to being Pro
Commission's under some other law which
is exactly what happens when Congress
passes a new version of the Commission's
act and he embraces them so I'll close
with and a story about that sort of
illustrates the themes that I've been
talking about so in 2013 when Ed Snowden
reveals many things among them the bulk
phone records program the Patriot Act
program and there's this sort of
eruption on the left and the right civil
libertarians on the Left libertarians on
the right Jim Sensenbrenner of all
people in Congress can't stand this
right this is not America and we don't
want this there's no there's no
political support then it leads
ultimately to the enactment of the USA
Freedom Act and it's sort of there for
some pretty surprising in cotton in
retrospect that Obama kept this thing
and one of the things I reconstructed
was the meeting at which he learned
about it and decided to keep it and that
was easy with February 4 February 6 6
2009 so he's been president for a couple
weeks and one of his few lawyer
political lawyers who knew about the
program because she had been national
security lawyer in the Senate and when
the FISA Amendments Act was enacted and
so I've got classified briefings really
wants the new president and his top team
to understand what it is they've
inherited in the surveillance world so
she organizes this briefing it's in the
Situation Room right after lunch and
Obama is late this is this is sort of a
fraught moment Dick Cheney has broken
with protocol to say to publicly attack
him and say that his decision to end the
black-site program and torture is going
to result in the United States being
attacked in a catastrophic way and the
day before Cheney says this and that
afternoon he's supposed to go meet
relatives of the victims of the 9/11
attacks and the Cole bombing who are
upset with him that he they frozen
military commission proceedings at
Guantanamo so it's a very sort of
stressful moment with the possibility of
an attack in the forefront of his mind
he comes in he's chewing nicotine gum
jaw so he's obviously a little bit
stressed and sitting around the
in the Situation Room are members of the
permanent security state the office of
Director of National Intelligence the
Federal Bureau of Investigation the
Central Intelligence Agency the National
Security Agency there are directors and
lawyers and Justice Department national
security officials people these are
these are Michael's people if people who
stay on between administrations and sort
of run the show
even as a George Bush is replaced by a
Barack Obama and so they explain these
programs here's what we're doing here
here's what we're doing here
and they get to the Patriot Act program
and they say well this allows us to
trace indirect links between people and
we can use it to hunt for hidden cells
associates of known terrorists that we
didn't know about hidden associates
Etta's and it's really important we
think if we'd had it in place before
9/11 we would have stopped those attacks
which is